Y
rodolfo garcía I am the biggest product here
for commercial see to my right I have to
Katherine
the designer of the group that created the
originator of the idea initially that
then we have it to nicolás also in
the developers that has been
programming together with federico the
application is basically about
a layer that overcomes what
already presented by your club
and what we did was mix the
web concepts with the concepts of
reality actually
of reality of real life
then the concepts of these two
we said good perfect pool grabbed and
put in digital everything we see in the
reality with street view from
this we create some virtual layer that
generates on that street view image
with the content that the user wants
put for example I am the owner of a
local that is on this area a street
and it's for the live post I'm also
the owner of placing a transparency to
through this application
that what he does and he can say
combine the concepts of reality and
virtual world with the benefits that
has the virtual world that is the scope
Quickly achieve effectiveness
who specifically is watching and the
concepts of reality that justly
is the location where they are
just the veracity of the person
that is presenting misinformation and
just align these two concepts
to be able to sell in a better way in
the Web
combining the concept of
classic advertising with everything that
offers the web